[Musique]
14 et de la chapelle voisine a semblé
heureux
[Musique]
les ordres des fiascos lui sa fièvre ici
ont brisé à vous
les enfants noah lamas les plus haut
[Musique]
vu que la soirée soit fait
c'est qu'armand
au 14 rue de la chapelle gives a perdu
l'habitude
on
une tasse à café de rome
pichet d'eau et de calmants
les enfants
15 10
je vous
rien à faire
parfois
tu fous là j'ai envie de bouger
[Musique]
pour des mais je me changera
je suis mal eux
[Musique]
changera
à
[Musique]
au 14 rue de la chapelle
sur sont tentés de blanc des paysages
pour l'un vertus anti tout le monde
souvent le soleil en avons compris mais
interdite
[Musique]
but
l'excès les enfants sont des chiens ans
au 14 rue de la chapelle d'humains la
journée sera belle
[Musique]
les visages sont connus
et des souvenirs à tout instant
[Musique]
quand et
gfr
jazz ou le coup et tu le sais
[Musique]
laisse moi
le porter mais je ne change
suivent pas le
il est souvent
[Musique]
un plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok ça lui ai dit oui je l'appelle stache
et ça fait vraiment du bien d'être là
avec du monde
enfin un petit peu mais c'est déjà
beaucoup je suis rentré un soir et je
les lui le regard et fitch croit plus je
pensais alors alors est-ce que c'est toi
tu n'as que toi c'est pas la première
faute du temps mal pour jean gougy dans
les yeux des autres images mais la 600
vaches nées la suite
je complète honte à toi
[Musique]
jeunesse athée toulouse
tous
ce
[Musique]
partir à l'abordage
ce visage tout
jveux lemptégy pas
j'ai tout fait dans ce compositeur et
café l'étape où ils quart d'heure faire
du surplace
mais ça l'est
[Musique]
ti-cats bas couserans
oh
cl
courage
[Musique]
et
g
[Musique]
si vous avez
ce
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment
descente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le coup ça fait vraiment plaisir
d'être là c'est fou quoi on se retrouve
ici
j'invite bourgeon se retrouvent à
bourges et manger migrent à tour mais
bourges c'est bien et c'est ma ville de
coeur aussi
[Musique]
j'ai peur du temps les juristes
j'exprime agir comme si l'ensemble de
ses biens vive à 2 c
tout quitter
[Musique]
tu partiras
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et que tu vu dans le passé justement
défini leur histoire soit parti
tu partir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu parles
l'outil
mais tous ces maux qui touchent ses mots
et c'est moi qui
les brise la vôtre
[Musique]
tu parti
dubé
qui
tu peux
que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'hésitez pas à taper des mains avec
nous
et si je m'étais aperçu
j'aurais pu bloquer les yeux du sens aux
antilles j'aurais plus construire un
ciel bleu ne faisant corps avec le
[Musique]
groupe
françois tu voulu construire en ciel
[Musique]
les fleurs données du coup dans le
paysage pas
seulement que
es tu en avais j'ai plus que les yeux
pour pleurer
mon coeur est fracassée et tout le sol
sans et anne k est un navet j'ai plus
que les yeux pour
c'est fera jaser tout ça
ou pas
[Musique]
ah mais je m'en moque de toi je dois
parler
je suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que
la fusion nous
vous
[Musique]
à
ça va passer une bonne soirée
oui aucun doute là dessus
[Musique]
après la vie du jeune
/ je vous
copé l'a alors
six mois d'août
je
principal jeu
g
là ce soir c'est sûr je côtoie voilà
[Musique]
lee
c'est
demain
[Musique]
tu solution du méchant attendons que
c'est l'avion
[Musique]
ce soit fait péter le couple central
une femme et ses dégâts et fait rire
le
et le
[Musique]
il
dans l'est
serra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon ça fait toujours autant du bien en
temps les gens peut dire ça fait du bien
de se retrouver à ici à tous ces gens
tous ses mains et je m'étais dit que
j'allais vous empêcher le de faire du
visio conférences des trucs comme ça un
peu chiant mais tous qu'on ne fait pas
tellement
[Musique]
m
et si dans mes yeux coule encore la
saveur une seule mais pas de ma vie
c'est la mienne
aulas voilà
[Musique]
olemps
merci
[Musique]
la tension est même un grand dieu comme
une
pour ce live
tout seul
alors je remplis sur dans ce délai doit
jeudi
comment
c'est grand place
eh oui
[Musique]
si je
certains
[Musique]
tendez
[Applaudissements]
alors alors
enfin
j'ai perdu des copains par excès d ela
fait vraiment
qu'attendu et le corps déchirés à
torturer il compile tous les lycées les
apps
j'ai compliquer l'accès voulez mais
chéri
comme vous
si j'avais voulu tenter
pour le
car tu es
les demi heures
suis levé
n'était qu'un
si le v
avait
golo six levées
des 15 lots 6
[Musique]
dans les eaux
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
ok j'aime accordéon peut reprendre vos
esprits tout doucement et jean profité
pour remercier du monde
on appelle ça un accordeur qui n'en fait
qu'à sa tête
je voulais remercier pierre cimon qui
est au sol et qui nous a accompagnés
depuis depuis maintenant presque six
mois je peux le dire s'il vous plaît du
bourg et pour pierre simon
l'homme qui a réalisé l'intégralité des
clips que vous avez vu derrière
il s'appelle yanis pas chaud s'il vous
plaît et derrière tapis dans l'ombre et
pourtant un grand acteur aussi de ce
concert
j'ai eu le poignet au réseau ok
mais
ala quart d'heure c'était la prise jack
[Musique]
patron
volontairement j'ai pas trop bouger mais
si je fais des trucs de la tête c'est
que c'était mes jambes
[Musique]
on
du coup elle est fausse j'en ai vu des
verts plein des gens on chantait jean
centaines puis à votre bon coeur oublier
en maquillage bien l'eau sur le vif
reste à limay couvrir la gueule de ses
comptant pour le père du délaissé tu
sens bon ton auteurs appellent la sûreté
pas c'est ma belle tu me murmure maudit
fruit de l'usure en mer parfum de soi
d'une main ferme dans le vase mes dix
doigts midi doit décider
antidote de terrain des démons ou bien
groupés sur mon front les graves je suis
l'homme éméché antidote déraper ou bien
poupe et où vont les graves et je suis
l'homme éméché
[Musique]
j'en ai vu des vertes et j'entends
chanter utilisons à votre bon coeur
oublier en matière vient de survenir
mais ce cap
bonne idée
tu sembles
son auteur appelle là je dis pas saine
ma belle tu me mur
moody free de l'usure a même parfois le
soir d'une ferme
le 20 mai du doigt des lois
[Musique]
antidote
je suis moche
ou bien
[Musique]
je
fiasco organisé un dîner danser
soulanges je veux les yeux j'ouvre les
yeux il est appelé va tuer rapidement
absorbé voyez 50 de l'entonnoir et puis
ça ne veut plus rien
bizarre si l'histoire en curieux même un
chien
joli coeur de moi je m'entendais fracas
je veux pas tenter fracas dans ma tête
c'est pas mexico le finir ma vie dans
tes mains tout droit
[Musique]
je suis le candidat
santi d'art thérapie
je suis là
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]